three more weeks of lockdown of
businesses closed of restricted
movements but these men are fuming about
something else
Abdul Rashid a shopkeeper in the
northern city of merit says Islamophobia
in India is at an all-time high
he squarely blames the Indian media
Corona has arrived this is what they say
when they see Muslims saying here comes
Corona is this a way to behave there is
a limit to our patience the
discrimination started after an event by
the Tablighi Jamaat
an Islamic sect was recognized as a
coronavirus hotspot many who attended
the gathering in Delhi became covered 19
carriers across India several media
channels were quick to claim that this
was a deliberate attempt to undermine
India some even allege in corona jihad
these allegations have also had a severe
economic impact muhammad idris would
normally travel through different
neighborhoods hawking his wealth some of
these were predominantly Hindu now
people refuse to let him in everyone is
turning us away the residents say don't
sell fruit here go back to your own
neighborhood
the police are stopping us too they're
beating us these Muslim vendors can now
only sell goods in their own majority
Muslim neighborhood business has dried
up elsewhere in Meerut rumors are
circulating about malicious intent
locals here are citing reports of
multiple incidences of Muslims entering
neighborhoods and spitting in them to
spread the coronavirus residents here
are standing guard and barricade in
gates to prevent this from happening
even leaders from the ruling BJP have
claimed that members of the Tablighi
Jamaat sect have deliberately spread the
virus India should have been free of
coronavirus by now but these Jamaat
members connected like suicide bombers
these suicide bombers should face the
strictest possible legal action they
should be punished in a way that
generations to follow will be too afraid
to commit such crimes the allegations
the sect has spread the virus on purpose
are still unfounded but fear and anger
across communities persists here for
these men their religion has become an
added burden during the long lockdown
and let's get more now we are joined by
the acclaimed novelist and political
activist our own hottie Roy from Delhi
thank you so much for joining us here on
DW news I'd like to begin by asking you
because lockdowns around the world have
been having disastrous consequences the
virus's implications as well what would
you like people to know about what is
taking place in your country in India
where inequality really exacerbates this
situation well I think what has happened
is the commad crisis in fact commad
itself is not a crisis yet in India if
you look at the numbers which you can
trust of course but little exposed
things about India that are so that all
of us knew but you know it's it's put it
on full display just as your reporter
was saying you know we are suffering not
just from comedy but from a crisis of
hatred from a crisis of hunger and of
course the lockdown in India is not a
lockdown because there is no physical
distancing there's just physical
compression but really this crisis of
hatred against Muslims it's coming of
course on the back of a massacre in
Delhi which was the result of of you
know since December
people protesting against the anti
Muslim citizenship law and now today
even as we speak
under the cover of Kovac the government
is moving to arrest young students to
file cases against lawyers against
senior editors against activists and
intellectuals some two of them recently
were put into jail so given that I mean
you describe this this crisis of hatred
what is your message then to the Hindu
nationalist government which is
apparently in flaming these tensions
further this inflaming these tensions
thought about that is its purpose
you know the whole the organization the
RSS to which Modi belongs which is the
mothership of the BJP has long said that
India should be a Hindu nation its
ideologues have likened the Muslims of
India to the Jews of Germany and if you
look at the way in which they are using
colleague it was very much like typhus
was used against the Jews to Decca buys
them to stigmatize them so there is
nothing I can say to to the government
that's all I can the only people I can
speak to are people in India and to the
world outside not to take this lightly
because honestly the situation is
approaching genocide you know because
the government's agenda has been this I
mean since this comment K Muslims have
been lynched Muslims have been hunted
down but now the stigmatization with
this illness has left you know
government policies on the street now
you can hear it everywhere and the the
it comes with a threat of extreme
violence and of really I mean already
they've started building these detention
centers and things for that citizenship
law but now you you know this will
dovetail with this illness to create
something which the world should really
keep its eyes on
I cannot exaggerate the threat more
so you you say that the crisis here is
approaching genocidal I mean that that
is really shocking if it has if it has
gotten to that point you wrote recently
in a piece sort of related to this you
said that the tragedy is immediate it is
real it is epic but it is not new it is
the wreckage of a train that has been
careening down the track for years whose
eyes have been closed and whose eyes
need to be open right now in order to
prevent what you see as the threat of a
genocide well that I wrote actually that
was I was talking about the u.s. health
system but it could as well apply to
what I'm saying now whose eyes are
closed the world's eyes are closed you
know every international leader is
hugging and welcoming the prime minister
who is really you know part of this
whole agenda even though he tries to
play the Statesman
he's quiet when the violence breaks out
in fact the massacre and then it
happened while Trump is here and Trump
said nothing no one says anything and
you know the the Indian media the
mainstream media is in the genocide
Almir Allah for the passions it is
within us not all of it but a lot of it
so TV anchors are like single member
lynch mobs you know sitting in their
studios so you you see what happens in
places like Rwanda and the role that the
media played there and you just see
these patterns repeating it's very very
very very frightening and here I'm not
even beginning to talk about the crisis
of hunger that is upon millions of
people in this country millions of
people the country 1.3 billion people
were shut down with 4 hours notice 8
p.m. he announced it 12:00 p.m. the
lockdown came and millions were stranded
on the streets with no food with nowhere
to go and walked hundreds of kilometers
home to their villages
they were not allowed in and the crisis
is deepening now the crisis of hunger
it's a really important message and we
thank you so much for joining us to
share it
Arundhati Roy as we mentioned you're an
acclaimed novelist political activists
you're also one of India's most
acclaimed intellectuals so we thank you
very much for joining us to share that
message
you